So accelerators are interesting,
there are a lot of accelerators.
There's accelerators that
universities have put together,
that corporations have put together,
and then there's the sort of private
investment vehicle accelerators like
Y Combinator, and there's a lot of them.
The interesting thing about
accelerators is the jury's still out
on the efficacy of accelerators.
There's a huge question out there of, if
a company goes to an accelerator program
or doesn't go to an accelerator program,
what are the odds of success?
Does an accelerate or
increase the likelihood of success?
And there's a lot of research going on
in that at Yael Hochberg at MIT and
Susan Cohen at the University of
Richmond are publishing all kinds of
papers, based on this
using crunch based data.
And we saw a recent study from U.C.
Berkeley, which showed that while
it's still difficult to tell whether
accelerators increase
the odds of success,
one thing that accelerators are doing is
they're making companies fail faster.
Because the mentors and the feedback
that the entrepreneurs are getting
help everybody understand,
is this a problem that's worth solving?
Is this a business that's
going to make it or not?
And it's moving much faster within
the environment of an accelerator
versus outside of an accelerator.
So that is something that
definitely has been proven thus.